[Music]
today the jury went into deliberations
and quickly found in favor of gwyneth's
one dollar countersuit was Gwyneth
Paltrow at fault no was Terry Sanderson
at fault yes what amount fairly
compensates Gwyneth Paltrow for economic
damages one dollar at first Gwyneth
remained emotionless when the verdict
was read then flashed a quick smile and
things got even Wilder when plaintiff
Terry Sanderson was called back to the
stand late yesterday did you compare my
client to King Kong was not my intention
like King Kong came out of the Jungle or
something I meant to say King Kong just
chased someone out of the Jungle
you're small But Mighty
actually you're not that small
I'm sure Gwyneth is watching as well
yeah
this weekend all lies will be on SNL to
see how host Quinta Brunson and the cast
tackles the spectacle Gwyneth actually
appeared in this 2019 goop spoof so what
does goop stand for oh
Gwyneth opens our paychecks as for the
looming domestic violence case against
Creed and MCU star Jonathan Majors his
lawyer provided E.T several alleged text
messages they claim proves he is
innocent
after the arrest a woman who calls
herself Jonathan's partner writes quote
I read about strangulation and I said
Point Blank this did not occur they said
they had to arrest you when they saw the
injuries on me I told them it was my
fault for trying to grab your phone
Jonathan's lawyer did not elaborate how
her alleged injuries occurred but
maintains he quote completely denies
assaulting the woman adding he called
9-1-1 due to her mental state
in one of the alleged messages she
writes I said to tell the judge the
origin of the call was to do with me
collapsing and passing out
foreign
[Music]